today on stick to football Antonio Brown
we're just waiting for this dude to be
suspended Zeke Elia is in the building
finally we're gonna break down your
couch football week - with previews and
picks
we're gonna go in-depth on Texas LSU and
boys we are catching flights probably as
people are listening to this I'll be in
the air mellow up in the air Conner will
be in the air because we are headed to
Austin [ __ ] Texas that's that's what
the people call it down there in Texas
we that we ask them that's what they
said Austin [ __ ] Texas I'm very
excited about the game I'm very excited
about the tailgate - that's gonna happen
pluckers I've been hearing about it for
months I'm so excited to get them in my
belly
yeah first-timer for me right here so I
have no idea what to expect you guys got
to realize I'm going Vegas Nashville to
Austin so I guess you're trying to kill
me oh we're gonna have a blast the
Miller brothers post-divorce tour like
this is what we've done previously so
it's almost like you got divorced
without the alimony and child support
you made t-shirts right we should Connor
Palooza 2019 at Austin Texas like Melo
said pluckers 230 on Rio Grande it's
gonna be a great time we'll be there for
about three hours so come hang out watch
us record the podcast but boys as we sit
here it is just after 4:00 p.m. Central
time on Thursday we are waiting to hear
from the Oakland Raiders regarding
Antonio Brown it came out Thursday
morning Adam Schefter dropped a bomb on
Twitter the a.b was upset and it just
got got worse and worse throughout the
day come to find out he had to be
restrained by Vaughn says Burfict which
is a sentence I never thought I would
say that someone was being restrained by
Montez Burfict from punching mike Mayock
and then told Mayock he was gonna punch
him this whole situation like I thought
helmet gait was bad I thought the
frostbit feet was bad
this dude is unhinged it's absolutely
ridiculous I mean I'm doing my day job
trying to keep up with everything and
it's just it's difficult to but the him
going up mike Mayock thing going after
the GM I think everybody probably could
have predicted this was going to happen
eventually I'm just glad that happens
the night that football kicks off it's
just then NFL is owning this Thursday
it's absolutely I mean I shouldn't say
it's hilarious but the fact that this
drama has somehow gotten worse is
unbelievable when it comes down to it I
almost feel like it you guys can tell me
if you feel differently
I don't think Antonio Brown plays it
down for the Raiders this summer I
really don't yeah and here's my tech
guys and you can tell me if you disagree
I don't think he wants to I think every
study every step along the way this
summer to me has said this dude does not
want to play football anymore I'm not
gonna play without my helmet oh my feet
hurt
now like what says to me that he wants
to be on the field and I wouldn't go to
Buffalo right wouldn't go to Buffalo if
I'm like man I would draw a line in the
sand and maybe he does today when we
hear from the Raiders maybe he says you
know what we've given this dude so many
opportunities we've supported him
through helmet gate through feet gate
we've supported him riding in a goddamn
hot-air balloon like we've been there
but we have 52 other players that we are
holding accountable and he's not one of
them so I would honestly I would void
his guarantees for conduct detrimental
to the team and I would cut his ass
tonight and move on not having to pay
him another dollar you probably won't
even have to cut him because I think the
Patriots would swoop in with a sixth or
seventh-round pick then they'd have to
pay him that all that you got I think
even tweeted it out like over the summer
like will a bee even play for the
Raiders on week one it was kind of a
joke doesn't look like much of a joke
anymore I think he's actually like kind
of questionable we'll see what happens a
suspension and he's probably not gonna
play a weak one a lot of news coming
down the pipe today when you don't show
up for work you get in trouble that's
what happens and it's a post on earth
road shade at me to post the fines the
letter from the GM yep
it's it's diabolical it's unbelievable
to think that this would just smooth
over it's like he's challenging them
each time something gets fixed he finds
a new issue to create with the team and
if you know mike Mayock he's not gonna
deal with that [ __ ] so for a B I
agree with you I think that he just
maybe doesn't want to play this year or
maybe somehow is already fed up in
Oakland maybe he finally realized that
Derek Carr is not that great I don't
know what it is but either way he's
really pissed off here's the thing I
want to know from you guys and this is
not on the rundown who would win in a
cage match I tweet
this poll who wins in a cage match mike
Mayock or a bee i think that mike Mayock
is a somewhat reasonable person and
those people usually don't fight as well
as batshit crazy people so a bee has
that on him and he's still in pretty
damn good shape so I think I'm gonna
take a Antonio Brown if I gotta pick
somebody in a fight yeah and when it all
comes down to it I think a bee can get
out of the cage a little faster than
mike Mayock at this point looks like
Peter [ __ ] up I don't know that's true
that's a good point
boy it's a ladder match I'm gonna take
mike Mayock and i'll say this it's
actually it's very like for the Oakland
fans this is extremely disappointing
because I think they've sat through a
rebuild this was something they were
supposed to be really excited about a
really great veteran player playing with
a young core and for him to do this
which is just it's flat-out selfish
there's no way around it
it's it's really disappointing for them
going into the season that this is what
they're talking about I want all the
cold takes from all of us saying like
the Raiders are gonna ice at it they're
gonna make the playoffs yeah you loved
that I did I loved them who would have
thought that there was a reason
Pittsburgh was willing to pay this dude
12 million dollars and let him go for a
third and a fifth
who'da thought yeah maybe Pittsburgh
knows what they're doing
I liked the signing when it happened to
bringing him in but I didn't expect
there would be this many headaches and
then bringing in the other guys like
incognito and Vaughn says perfect whoo
thank god for mike Mayock that he did
bring in Vantaa his birthday but i just
i didn't see how that was gonna work
once you start getting all those pieces
in a locker room and then you're doing
the complete opposite with your draft I
think he was trying to balance out that
locker room with all these high
character guys with good work ethic and
then you're signing these veterans who
have some questions surrounding them big
news for Hunter Renfro that's what today
is let's move on guys Zeke Elliott
someone who handled his business a
little bit differently than a B signs a
six year 90 million dollar contract 50
million of that is guaranteed which is
actually what we thought would happen
happened
he gets the most guaranteed money for a
running back surpasses Todd Gurley in
that that area
he's now locked up for a very long time
I remember hearing when they drafted
Zeke a person who was a GM at the time
as not anymore told me they're gonna run
him into the ground for five years and
then they're gonna keep him at somehow a
franchise tag or short-term deal for a
year two more and then they're gonna
walk
away from it they're just gonna use him
as hardened as fast as they can and then
let him go it seems like this deal it
really is like a two-year deal and then
they kind of have an out here yeah and I
mean the six-year extension for a
running back is absolutely ridiculous
and then that guaranteed money with the
50 million guaranteed I don't know where
the Cowboys are getting all of their
money but apparently Jerry Jones is just
printing it down there it will be
interesting to see like you guys talked
about in the midweek show like who's the
odd man out I agree I think it's
probably gonna be Jones at corner with
them just locking up everybody you can't
let dak go I think they're gonna keep
Amari and then Zeke gets his deal done
so good for the Cowboys I would like to
see them be successful I think they're
one of the few teams in the NFL where
football is better when the Cowboys are
winning I know that our in a fit NFC
East fans probably don't like to hear
that Redskins Giants Eagles but I think
football is better when the Cowboys are
good a lot of money here a lot of money
but I do think the the max value always
tells a different story than the real
the real guaranteed dollars here for
Zeke and of course he's now the
highest-paid running back and I think
when it comes down to it though he's
still really young that's the thing
you're getting him in his prime when the
guaranteed money is up in this deal it's
you know maybe the wheels will fall off
the bus there and they will run him into
the ground but the Cowboys know the
player they have they know how vital he
is to that offense playing behind that
offensive line helping dak Prescott know
so Amari Cooper takes some pressure off
him somebody else we think will get an
extension there this one just simply
unlike the Melvin Gordon situation this
deal simply had to get done yeah no one
is trading a first rounder from Melvin
Gordon by the way no one's trading a
second round I don't know if anyone's
gonna trade a third rounder for him I
don't know if anyone's trading format
this poor child trade bucket yeah no
trades for him Melo you have some of the
rundown here hours you Night Football
the recap yes because we record on
Thursday nights I didn't want to do a
disservice to our fan base for missing
out on Thursday Night Football so when
you're listening to this Friday we're
gonna go ahead and recap the game for
you what happened what went down it was
a great game 100-years Lambeau Field
great atmosphere I love what the Bears
were able to do on defense Mitch true
Biscay looked like a completely
different quarterback I really think
that we're seeing him
grow this year another year with Matt
naggy and I'll tell you Connor David
Montgomery going off and game one like
he did feels got absolutely feels good
easing to have him as indicated the two
of you are just absolutely vindicated
I'm happy for you boys go bears bear
down obviously yeah I just I feel bad
for Aaron Rodgers throwing the
interception what he did
timely no get a great game he had a
really great game I think the offseason
of of being you know not in the
spotlight it was Pat mahomes his
offseason for once Aaron Rodgers came
out pissed off came out slinging it
early but just not enough to beat
Chicago yeah Matt Lafleur is already on
my hot seat guys you know he has to be
another hire if you look at his body
language on the sidelines from tonight's
game it was just you you can tell
there's something up there already week
one tough scene for the for the Packers
all right that's our recap of Thursday
Night Football we take a break we come
back we're gonna break down week two of
the college football season games that
actually haven't happened yet it's time
to break down week two I'm laughing at
mellow we're on YouTube now blitz
Roberts YouTube channel look for us it
no sure you can see my mouth network now
to Monday mornings Wednesday mornings
Friday mornings and except for this week
because we'll be able to tell you it's
or snow video Monday but Melo is like
making jokes before we roll and then we
rollin up laughing so it's just we have
to do that great well I don't even know
what it's called pre-roll we count in
yeah and so I was doing the it was that
the Kyler Murray you're like Kyler
Mercer I never know when I'm gonna
I really don't never know when you're
gonna go let's get into week two
previews and pics let's start it here
West Virginia at Missouri guys Missouri
-14 62 and a half
over/under Melo I'm gonna take the over
on this one and I tell you I like
Missouri I know that they just lost to
Wyoming and people love to get my
Twitter mentions about oh did you see
what they did last week I did and that's
why I think this is a Redemption game
for them it's their first home game in
Columbia because they lost on the road
in Wyoming and I think maybe that
altitude had something to do with it but
I like them against West Virginia West
Virginia didn't really impress me last
week I think that Kelly Bryant Roundtree
I think they get the offense going I
hope to see more Alberto this week I
like Missouri I like Missouri big 14
point favorite I don't know if I would
bet on the point
but if I'm betting outright I do like
Missouri to win this game yeah I bet now
right I'm going with Missouri as well I
do think West Virginia covers in this
game that line is juicy it's a fat line
at 14 points there but when you look at
it at the simple fact is neither of
these teams are very good right now but
Missouri needs a big bounce back and
this is probably just what the doctor
ordered for them so you're both taking
Missouri yep
straight up yet you need coverage though
I'm taking some country roads take me
home
singing who the place a song Scott you
feeling that way I don't think they'll
cover I'll say that I don't think
there's any way but no I I'm gonna take
West Virginia I just don't believe in
Missouri I know West Virginia is down
but I think Missouri coming off a loss
to Wyoming I think they are just primed
for a surprise game and I West Virginia
is a good enough team there's still some
talent there for them to shock Missouri
on the air mellow we're actually tied at
six and four so I also just had to take
a different game than you number twelve
Texas A&M at number one Clemson the
Tigers favored by 17 and 9 oh my god and
64 and a half is the over guys I am
going to take the over definitely taking
the over I'm gonna take Clemson to win
this but I actually think am covers
Clemson is not this special juggernaut
we saw that last week when they
struggled I do expect a better game from
Trevor Lawrence but kelan Mondt
and this am offense they were good
enough to keep things interesting
even in Death Valley yeah I hate it when
we agree but I'm gonna agree with you on
this one for a lot of the reasons you
just pinpoint it I do think this is
gonna be a high offense here so I'm
gonna take the over as well and you're
right I think anm can do enough on
offense that they keep it close I don't
know if they're ever really gonna be in
this game I think Clemson can jump on
them early but I also think that they'll
stay within like 13 14 points I don't
think it'll get too out of hand so I'm
gonna take Clemson I probably would stay
away from Betty in this game it just
seems like it could be an upset but I am
gonna take Clemson yeah you have to
wonder if Trevor Lawrence is gonna be
looking for that bounce-back kind of
game after you know falling down the
heisman rankings a little bit and maybe
get those numbers back up I expect to
shoot out in this game hopefully my
cousin kendrick rogers has another big
game here against Clemson we'll see but
it's just hard to pick against Clemson
in this one as much as
don't love that line that's a lot to ask
for them to cover in this one against a
pretty good am team it's a lot of am
disrespect honestly and I've like trash
Jimbo Fisher on this show but seventeen
and a half is a hell of a lot alright
number twenty five Nebraska at Colorado
a huge rivalry game here Nebraska is
favored by three and a half 64 and a
half's the over/under guys I'm gonna
take the under
I think Nebraska wins outright I also
think they cover in this one Colorado's
I like Montes Colorado's is not that
good I think Nebraska gets back on track
this week and that's where you're wrong
because I'm going to take the under as
well and Colorado I really like what
they're doing the way they performed
last week against Colorado State was a
real test when you understate exactly
when you look at this Nebraska team
though they struggled against South
Alabama they put up 35 points but they
gave up 21 to South Alabama that's why I
think a guy like LA viscus Chennault can
come in here get the ball in his hands
he can score every time I think by
himself he can put up 21 in this game so
I'm actually gonna take an underdog here
and we call those the super underdog
locksmith of the week to bet your money
on because I don't have the nuts to make
my own money so pause three and a half
for Colorado I like it take it against
Nebraska I don't know if Scott frost has
these things rolling yet last year it
took six games for them to do it I think
maybe we see that same thing this year I
did not like what I saw last week from
Nebraska came away very underwhelmed but
with that being said I'm gonna stick
with them I think they do get back on
track here I do think this is a win for
them I even think it's a cover here I
really do I think Colorado's got some
talent I'd like to see she not really
take over the game and they get creative
with how they get him the ball whether
it's screens sweeps obviously throwing
in the ball but Nebraska I think they
have a statement win this week there
this game is at 2:30 so it will be
happening during our live cast recording
and tailgate tour so how about loser
shotguns a beer Oh fantastic okay there
you go we're just adding so bad that you
two actually have to do it when you lose
and we'll be giving away hoodies so if
you really want to stick to football
hoodie you come to pluckers there you go
if you made it to this point in the show
you get those little tabs right this is
where we really give you the info you're
12 minutes in what I get here
and code I don't have anymore I would
give them away
number 23 Stanford at USC this is the
surprise of the week for me
USC is favored by a point the over-under
is only 45 this is ridiculous I don't
understand I know it's at USC I don't
think they have a home-field advantage
anymore I'm taking Stanford inning and I
obviously believe that they will cover
in this one yeah I agree with you too
literally betting right now this game it
sucks I don't want to say that but it
sucks that both starting quarterbacks
are gonna be out we saw KJ Costello go
down and then we see JC Daniels get hurt
as well so we have to backup
quarterbacks and that's the difference
for me in this game because Stanford
brings in a guy who's been there for a
little bit with Mills and USC is gonna
start a true freshman at quarterback
that's not good against the Stanford
defense I know that they couldn't score
last week but they stopped Northwest
from scoring and their quarterback
couldn't do anything now you're
introducing a freshman to this I think
that Stanford can get the job done even
though they are playing at USC Matt like
you mentioned that's not really a
home-field advantage for them anymore so
I know shit-talk here for the USC fans I
hope you guys program gets back but
right now I'm taking Stanford the
quarterbacks is just the difference
maker
yeah Stanford knows how to travel
they'll be ready for this game this line
is just kind of laughable in my opinion
I understand it's because USC is home
but you got a ranked Stanford team
coming in they'll be just fine Stanford
all the way like I actually want to bet
on this and you know my big complaint is
we can't legally bet in Missouri legally
fitting the keyword it's crazy so I'm
gonna vinh moc honor some plenty and
please take care of those New Jersey
laws for me on this one buddy all right
game of the week fellas
number six LSU at number nine Texas
that's nice
Texas plus six fifty five and a half is
the over/under and I'm gonna go last I
don't want I'm gonna all right well it
it pains me to do this I hate to do it
but I would rather be right I think that
LSU is gonna win this game I think it's
gonna be a very tough atmosphere for LSU
to come into because the fan base is
gonna be ready this isn't the opening
game it's not the home opener so it's
gonna be a little bit different
McConaughey is gonna be
their side lines are gonna be packed but
I do not like the depth of this Texas
team now they're going they're limited
to almost I'd say one and a half running
backs right now because they're second
string running back is their third
string quarterback and he's a freshman
he never played running back until he
got to Texas kiante Ingram I don't know
if he's a guy that can carry the load
for this Texas team only like 11 carries
last week that worries me I think
they're gonna have to be able to move
the ball rushing in order to beat LSU
and I don't know if they can do that
they can't put it all on Sam Ehlinger
the defense has holes and jobber oh
absolutely lit it up last week five
touchdowns LSU looks like they have in
offense and we know they have a great
defense I hope LSU loses but I think
they're gonna win
yeah hey doing this before we even get
they're not gonna be making a lot of
friends but I'm picking LSU in this one
I'm sorry I'm sorry I just think they
just have more talent across the board I
was looking at the defense today it's
like their entire defense can be drafted
it's absolutely ridiculous then you see
how burrow comes out now this is a test
for burrow because the the cupcake is
over here burrows gonna be tested a
little more in this one obviously on the
road but I think LSU is gonna win this
game that line is a little big though
and I know Matt's gonna go somewhere
else here with this you think guys
because I believe in Tom Herman I
believe in Sam Allen gur I'm going with
Texas this is what Tom Herman does he
always wins
underdog games always we saw him beat
Oklahoma last year in the Red River
shootout we saw him beat Georgia in the
Sugar Bowl so you say oh I don't know
counting could be the guy he can be and
I don't know the Christian bulletin can
stop what they have in Colin Johnson
that's gonna be one of the best matchups
of Saturday matchup that's Howard
Johnson's size and his awareness I'm
taking Texas I'll take the [ __ ]
points now I think we maybe need to put
a bet down on this one too but also I
want to see his Sam Bellinger carry one
out of the pocket and I want to see what
happens with grant Delfin not not chase
on please God don't let that happen but
grant Delpit I want to see if he can lay
the wood on a big guy like Sam Ehlinger
hopefully both of them walk away healthy
from that but I it's gonna be a very
good game obviously that's why we've
highlighted on the tailgate tour that's
why it's our game of the week here very
excited about it
sadly I just think LC was gonna win yeah
I'm sorry Joe Perot beat up Georgia
[ __ ] southern okay you're excited
that big win big I mean I like this
talent you look good but it was Georgia
Southern they don't have cadence turns
back there or big Brandon Jones or BJ
foster so it's gonna be a great game we
know that we're gonna be down there
having a lot of fun I'm already fired up
just think how Saturday nights gonna be
Oh coming in low that way when Texas
does win I don't care if I'm wrong I'll
be very excited I'll be running down
Beaver Boulevard naked screaming I was
right hey so come for that too I almost
did that last weekend alright boys it is
top five time and this week because it
is basically Texas LSU week here on
stick to football we're gonna rip
through the current top five Texas
players that's Melo the current top five
LSU players that's Connor and then I'm
gonna give you the top five draft
prospects from the two teams combined so
big on the Tigers and Longhorns this
week because we're all super excited so
mellow you're up first the top-five
current Texas players I'm gonna take the
top five guys here and I went more from
a college point of view than a draft
point of view since you'll be talking
about some of these guys but I think it
does start with Sam L longer for Texas
maybe as a draft prospect unsure about
that one yet but definitely as a college
football player I think he's one of the
most electric college football players
playing right now so it starts there
with me what he's able to do with his
arm hopefully it's consistent I actually
thought that he missed a lot of throws
last week against Louisiana Tech so
hopefully he can correct that against a
very good secondary possibly DBU and LSU
and then next I'm gonna go with Colin
Johnson a guy that I actually think
really helped out sammelan year last
week making the sideline catch adjust in
his body he really impressed me he was a
guy that I was actually kind of low on
through the draft process but he's
coming out and proving that he's a very
valuable piece to this often so I really
like him and then our guy
not stick to football guy cadence turns
all of us love him I want to see what he
can do cuz now it is time to show up for
Kaden Stearns last week I thought he
kind of played he disappeared for a
little bit he can't against LSU he's
gonna have to be in there playing over
the top with another guy that I have at
safety Brandon Jones I like both of
these guys I like how they complement
each other with one being able to play
in the box
you can both kind of slide in that
nickel position Caden Stearns is a guy
that I think we're gonna be talking
about a lot not this year obviously
because he's a sophomore but next year
in the draft or hopefully if you're a
Texas fan like me the next year because
you will stay for all four years and
let's just stay with the secondary
because they also have a very young guy
and BJ foster who is also a true
sophomore a lot of young talent in the
secondary I think he's been overshadowed
by cadence turns six to two ten plays
the nickel plays safety as well I really
like what he can do I like his potential
I think by the end of the year that
we're gonna be talking about those two
safeties being a very special tandem
yeah so for LSU I went with the more
draft eligible eligible approached here
since I can't always read sometimes so
we're gonna have some fun with this one
here and these are the players we've
been watching all summer but Grant selpa
is the best safety in the country I
think it's as pretty as simple as that
now you still got to go earn it he's a
young player here we'd like to see him
make some plays against a good Texas
team so all eyes on grants out but I
don't think there's gonna be
disagreement from anyone there now I
will say across the field from him
though brand Jones the cadence turns I
think that's the best safety duo in the
country so makes this matchup extra
interesting Christian full and really
liked what he can do at corner we got to
see him in person last year against
Georgia thought he played very very well
there's times he was better than greedy
Williams last year so all eyes on
Christian fallin now the wild card of
the group that's Kayla Vaughn Jason I
think with him the injury last year we
don't really know but we have
expectations that he could be a
top-flight passed rusher and I think
we're gonna start to see that as this
year goes on he gets back to form I
think you're talking about somebody
where we don't know if he's gonna be
back in school next year if he's gonna
be a first-round pick so the ends the
spectrum is very big for a guy like
chase on Jacob Phillips that linebacker
he's a tackling machine he finds the
ball it's as simple as that LSU always
has these you know sake athletic kind of
linebackers Phillips is next in line and
Rashard Lawrence is you know the rare
LSU player that's actually been there a
little bit now
team leader team captain should see him
in Mobile at the Senior Bowl this year
is one of those defensive linemen down
in the trenches so when you're looking
for draft eligible talent from LSU and
all starting talent right here
they're absolutely loaded it was hard to
leave someone like Joe
burro off this list their quarterback
but I want to see more you know pro
things that he can do or times where
he's not just there to obviously you
know just go along for the ride go ahead
and win them some games I think you
could start that while on the road in
Austin this weekend know what I just
remember that I forgot I have a $500 bet
with Foster Morrow on this game it's to
charity Wow
but it's five bills about me nope I'm
good no thing is to charity so it's for
a good cause so my top five draft
prospects from this game a number one is
obviously grant dealt but I think he has
a special safety prospect he reminds me
a lot of Derwin James now the thing that
we need to see from him like we saw
really the second half of durman's last
year floor just a we need to see big
plays from Grant Dell but because so far
we've seen the bike type and the
athleticism the characters obviously
there but I want to see play making
ability games like this one games
against Georgia games against Alabama or
where we really need to see him flash I
expect we will see him be asked to spice
a Mellinger will be asked to see him
cover Conte Ingram out of the backfield
as a receiver so granted this could be a
signature game for him up next
again draft prospects here Caleb on
chase sounds one of my favorite players
in the country win and healthy and we've
only seen flashes from him in that
freshman season like Connor said will he
be an NFL guy for this year I believe he
will be he's already rocking number 18
which is a pretty good sign of what is
to come for him guys normally we're 18
and then they're out of there for a year
after that so I think chase on as he
knocks off some rust and he did have a
quiet game last week but again it was
Georgia Southern so I think he'll that'd
be a really good test him against the
Texas offensive line which is pretty
young Sam Cosme the left tackle Derek
Kerstetter at right tackle those are
gonna be good matchups for what we see
from Chase on Christian bullet will be
third for me and this is an LSU
dominated list at the top here and it's
dominated by the back seven on defense
Bolton has excellent size he's physical
but again we're gonna see him matched up
against Colin Johnson this weekend
that's who's next on my list that
matchup between those two players he's
one of the best from the college
football season it's definitely the best
scouting matchup of week two just seeing
the size of Colin Johnson who has such a
massive catch radius
extend so well and what we saw week one
like
melot said was adjustment from him I
really feel like his first two years he
was this big you know tall kind of stiff
and rigid receiver if we see added
agility from him
he could be a first-round prospect at
the wide receiver position and then
number five for me a player that I I
know will not enter the 2020 NFL Draft
but I got to put him on here anyway
is Sam Ellen Kerr now I have questions
about his arm strength and I know last
year he was hurt with the shoulder
injury and that affected his arm
strength umph I almost think he's a
little bit too bulky in the upper body
that affects some of his motion he gets
a little bit rigid right here in his
motion and I think that does affect
velocity a little bit but his toughness
his leadership his field vision his
playmaking ability are all really really
top-notch so i think sam millinger is
right there i want to throw it one name
that i know the staff at texas is super
excited about that is not draft eligible
yet but jaylen green at corner is gonna
be someone to watch there are people
there that believe he's the best player
in that entire secondary there's some
guys that look he's the best player on
defense yeah a great spring game and he
had a big game last week and he's the
only guy that really solidified himself
as a starting corner
they were looking a lot of these other
guys cook is another sophomore that ever
looking at and Jalen green was the
standout guy that say okay this has to
be our lockdown corner every other job
was open he's the only guy that really
showed up and and won that job
immediately draft on draft tomboys
Patrick Chamberlain first question now
that the season is upon us what's single
in a filthy line are you most excited to
watch unfold this season no one cheat in
San Antonio Brown I'm gonna let Connor
go a little bit weak because I he's
maybe gonna say for me it's the second
year quarterbacks I don't really care
about the rookies Dwayne Haskins not
gonna play right away Daniel Jones not
gonna play right away Kyler Murray
they're gonna lose a lot of games over
there in Arizona for me it's the
second-year quarterbacks I look at you
know Ken Lamar Jackson grow as a pastor
Ken Sam darn old and Josh Allen cut down
the turnovers and not just you know
manage the game but lead their offenses
well Josh Rosen survived in Miami that's
something that we want to know and his
Baker Mayfield the superstar that he's
been billed as already I think that's
the one for me where you know
something's been written about the each
of them whether it's Lamar can't throw
or
you know Josh Allen is making these
Crossfield throws and turning the ball
over Josh Rosen's d'Honneur Baker
Mayfield's already a star I want to see
how it all shakes out rather than
talking about it four five six seven
months yeah I agree and with Baker I
think one of the it's like there are
camps with Baker you know it's like
Baker's the next superstar or you got
the people who are like Baker wasn't
good against good defenses last year so
I think it's gonna be interesting to see
what what does happen this year what
comes from that Melo your top story line
I was gonna take actually the
second-year quarterback split
specifically Sam Darnell I really want
to see what he can do with Le'Veon Bell
there I think that's gonna be a great
matchup for them being able to get the
ball to him out of the backfield I think
that's gonna be key I had him as my
quarterback one I want to see what he
can do this year with a good running
game with some more weapons on offense
with a better offensive line so mine was
Sam Darnell but I do agree with you
Conor the second-year quarterback so
let's really see what we have with these
guys especially Josh Rosen Lamar Jackson
I want to see what they can do on the
field I'm pretty confident with the
first two Baker Mayfield in Sam Donald I
think they'll do just fine I don't see
Josh Allen another year see what he can
do he's another guy that has a better
offensive line more weapons around him
now his running back so I'll agree with
you Conor on the second-year
quarterbacks yeah for me I think there's
a lot you know it's it's I'm fascinated
by some of the team building that we're
seeing you know Cleveland and Oakland
have bought teams you know outside of
you know like they drafted Baker
obviously in Nick Chubb but they've
brought in high-profile players will
that work we already seen it unravel in
Oakland Miami is tanking how will that
work but I think for me like the biggest
storyline is we see teams like the
Chicago Bears who are built so much on
defense and now a strong run game will
they be able to win in today's NFL where
everything favors the offense where the
Rams are more spread it out than ever
before we've seen teams like Green Bay
Cincinnati make hires to where they're
gonna try to spread it out more they've
you know everyone's going for the Shawn
McVeigh style often so I want to see
that can defenses still win in the NFL
the Super Bowl was all about defense 13
to 3 the Patriots really dominated that
game and we're able to slow down Jer
Gulf so can a team like Chicago can they
compete in a league where the Rams
achieve some Saints are just trying to
score 60 points every week so that's one
thing that fascinates me
second question guys from Jeremy Gordon
what positions do you think are under
and overvalued the most in professional
football or college football yeah I
think you actually have to say the
offensive tackle position you look at
left tackle we almost have no one coming
out that's any good I'll take my Kansas
City Chiefs to use as an example I think
they have the best offense in college in
the NFL and they don't have a very good
left tackle and for years we said okay
after you get your quarterback you have
to have somebody at that left tackle you
have to protect the Blind Side because
of a movie with Sandra Bullock no
actually you don't you can put somebody
on the right side of that offensive line
and they will do just fine so I actually
think that left tackle has become very
overrated and running back it's still
very underrated I know that you can find
these guys all over the place but it
still it really helps your offense there
are not very many teams that do have a
great offense without having some kind
of piece in the running game and even
the Kansas City Chiefs last year with
Kareem hunt there for that short time
and then Williams stepping up into that
role they still had a viable option at
running back yeah I don't think that's
crazy at all I think when you look at it
teams if they want to get home they'll
find a way one offensive lineman can't
just solve everything I think in a way I
know the value of the corner position
has not fallen off it's definitely
increased but if you have a number one
corner and nothing around him teams will
just throw away from you they'll find a
way to win so at times chasing that
number one corner all the time like
here's an example that that hits close
to home this is funny one gets gave
Tremaine Johnson 90 billion dollars and
their secondary sucks and even when he
plays it sucks and also his plays fallen
off but teams can just throw away from
him so it's more about building the
entire secondary finding value safeties
finding slot guys on day three of the
draft and building the entire unit I
think the secondary specifically corner
has been very similar to how mello broke
down the left tackle situation yeah I
think one of the most overvalued is
tight end because a good tight end okay
it's nice but you better have that many
one like if you don't have Gronk or
Travis Kelce or Zach Ertz like okay who
[ __ ] cares like you you probably got
a guy who's gonna catch 40 balls I guess
tonight they're not difference-makers
offensively we haven't seen OJ Howard
break out I don't know if TJ Hawkinson
can ever live up to his draft stock
unless he's a hall-of-famer
so no offense same way I just think
Titan has become it really has become
overvalued
I think undervalued this is a prediction
and I know I'm stealing something Melo
has said for years we're gonna see the
full-back come back this year in a big
big way because people are just gonna
try to hammer these these small three by
two by seven defenses three by two by
six defenses where everyone's just let
me throw as many DB's out there as
possible and you're you can beat those
up so I think we're gonna see the
full-back come back you've already seen
like some of the roster construction
where teams are actually they're adding
full backs again so that's my
undervalued position a little bit of a
Homer pick and I also the only offensive
line your center is so important yes and
we don't we talk about left tackle so
much and now there's right tackle talk
because of Lane Johnson and Mitchell
Schwartz but goddamn that Center better
be good because that's where it all
starts and when you have to worry about
guys like Aaron Donald and Fletcher Cox
and now Quinn and Williams and Ed Oliver
and Rashad Gert just freaks you better
have a really good center right Lee
Lovelace says the good Lord Himself
comes down and tells you that your NFL
team will win the Super Bowl if you do
not watch a single second of any of
their games that season would you do it
and is it worth it I would if it like I
wouldn't care if they won if I couldn't
see it right yeah isn't that the point
is that you get to watch and enjoy as
you follow along like I'm yeah I'm there
I just slide 26 miserable seasons as a
Jets fan and I'm gonna not watch any of
it and they win what's the point of that
yeah same with me and my Kansas City
Chiefs that year last year that I was a
fan it really I enjoyed watching it even
though we didn't win the Superbowl
yeah I just don't think there's any way
like I mean as a Niners fan I've seen I
for I'm not that selfless three or four
if there's Super Bowls houses some lose
one there's no way I want that moment of
like who cares if you wake up the next
day like oh my team won the Super Bowl
so no I'll say this I might agree to it
in baseball because the Mets would find
a way for it to be miserable if they
weren't a World Series they would just
find a way so as long as they just win
it and I can go around and be happy in
New York
the next Mets Royals World Series
appearances will probably be against
each other again
like that's just the way it's gonna hack
on her the thing is none of us would be
alive to see it when they're done with
their 28-year rebuild yeah all right
Roma Thomas off last question who would
you rather have on your fantasy team and
to start an NFL team with Alva Kimora or
Christian McCaffrey stuff I know mine
though I'm gonna go with McCaffrey yeah
me too I had the second pick at our
fantasy draft and I glowed it a little
bit because I got say Kwan somehow but
if you're giving me those two guys I
would have went with McCaffrey I liked
his body of work last year I like that
he's taking care of his actual body too
putting on a little bit more weight to
carry the load and he's I think he's
just as dangerous out of the backfield
catching the ball he just hasn't been I
mean he you have one play with Drew
Brees you have one playing with Cam
Newton so I'm gonna take McCaffrey
yeah it's McCaffrey for me as well I'm
really curious to see how Kamara handles
that workload this year we've seen
McCaffrey handle an absolutely
ridiculous ridiculous workload before so
I'm just more confident I think they're
both phenomenal players in terms of
talent the gaps really not that big I
just I'm more confident right now
McCaffrey staying healthy for the long
term and and really just carrying that
offense we've had both guys on the
podcast too so we can even play
favorites be like oh this one's been on
I would say that Kamara was a little
guest
yeah I'm actually gonna take Kamara I
just I like his style a little bit more
he's a little bit bigger but just just a
little bit but I do I like I just like
the physicality he plays with Ivan
Christian is so slippery and he does
have some power this game but I like
that Kamara and maybe this is not good
because we've never seen him be a
featured back but I do like that he'll
get a little more physical with the ball
on his hands no wrong answer there oh
you know great to have either one of
them I will - I mean the Saints spent a
little bit less on draft Capital and
then the Panthers did but either one of
those guys you should be good in fantasy
team or real football before we close
this show what is your guys concern
level with Odell Beckham's comments
about his hip I haven't seen them I
didn't either he breaks in it's a little
scary I'll read it to you
he basically feels that he
not Fogo yet right now because of his
hip the quote was and this is from Mary
Kate Cabot the car can still go but it's
dangerous it's something that prevents
me from opening up and sprinting yeah
I'm very concerned especially if he's if
he's saying that like he has no reason
to put out false information I don't
think that is that's not good it's not
good that's scary man
and I I love Odell and I actually just
tweeted today like all this a be trauma
and Odell supposed to be the diva and
he's just like quietly doing a [ __ ]
maybe he's just in too much pain to talk
yeah that's a little bit scary I would
be interested to see what comes of that
man
these teams got to protect their
superstar so hopefully they're managing
it yeah yes we can see we've seen a lot
of teams do that with obviously what
they're doing in training camp but you
don't need to risk getting a guy like oh
no Beckham hurt anymore hopefully is
okay because I do want to see that
Browns offense
I'm obviously I would like to see
certain members of that offense fail but
he's not one of them
no Odell's great alright boys that is
our show the next time you hear us we
will be in Austin Texas at pluckers
having a blessing this good time you
won't be able to see us be only here us
you can come see us though on Rio Grande
232 five-ish 530 ish depending on when
we decide to head to the stadium but
come say hey let's have some Lone Star
let's have some shiner we'll be giving
out some merch and we'll be doing the
show live so you can get involved get
your voice on the podcast with some
draft on draft questions so safe travels
to Melo and Connor thank you to everyone
watching this on youtube if you have not
already go and hit that subscribe button
on youtube on itunes on spotify wherever
you're checking us out we'll holler at
you all Monday morning